in A Song of Ice and Fire and Game of
Thrones Westeros is threatened by an
army of the Dead bringing a night that
never ends according to prophecy the
only hope is a hero known as azor Ahai
or the prince that was promised the text
suggests that John or Daenerys or both
are azor Ahai but could the Savior be
someone furrier so pounce is one of King
Tommen x' kittens along with lady
whiskers and boots
the kins are given to him by Margaery
Tyrell and we're not told where Margaery
gets the kittens but we can actually
make a pretty good guess Margaery lives
in the red cape and the Cape is full of
cats including kittens we also know
marjorie likes to look after the poor
and vulnerable
so maybe Margaery finds Sir pounce and
the others as strays in the Cape and
offers them to Tommen as a way of caring
for them if the kittens are strays from
the Cape we can work out who their
father may be io chases many cats around
the Cape but one of them is special
a Tomcat with black fur one year and a
reputation he snatches food out of
Tywin's fingers scratches Joffrey
attacks Ravens in the Rookery a gold
clerk calls him a black bastard older
than sin and twice as mean Tommen calls
him the bad cat but we might call him
anyway so this is a black cat living in
the red cape it just so happens that so
pounce and his siblings are also black
cats who may have been born in the red
cape we've been told of course that the
seed is strong black hair color can
indicate parentage so it's very possible
likely even that this Tomcat is so
pounces father the reason why that would
be cool is that the Tomcat is described
as the real king of the castle
if so pounces father is a king so pounce
is a prince and Tommen makes a promise
to Cersei to let him have kittens making
sir pounce a prince that was promised a
phrase used to refer to as Ora hi is it
possible that sir pounce is the
prophesied savior of the world
let's do this properly see if Sir pounds
fits what we know of the hero azor Ahai
for starters it said that the dragon
must have three heads and so pounds has
lady whiskers and boots but the most
important stuff of these seven signs
azor Ahai is prophesied to be born
beneath the bleeding star apparently
referring to the red comet that appears
at the end of the first book we don't
know when sir pounce is born but we do
know he's still a kitten in dance which
is roughly a year after the last
sighting of the comet in clash it
apparently takes about a year until the
kitten is called a cat so it's totally
possible that sir pounce is literally
born beneath the comet the bleeding star
azor Ahai is prophesied to be born
amidst salt and smoke the red cape
overlooks the salty sea or at least
Blackwater Bay which Davis says is salty
and the Cape is led by torches that
produce smoke so that all pretty much
fits azor Ahai is prophesied to have a
red or burning sword which Sam and John
suggest might just mean a Valyrian steel
sword as far as we know so counts does
not have a sword in fact he doesn't have
thumbs which may pose a problem with the
grip but we do know that little finger
has a Valyrian steel knife which may be
small enough for a cat to hold like in
its mouth yeah so yeah put that down as
a maybe azor Ahai is said to need a
sacrifice and so pounce catches a mouse
for what that's worth
azor Ahai has something to do with
dragons or to wake dragons out of stone
Danny's dragon eggs are described as
stone and she wakes them by making them
hatch could the dragon skulls in the red
cape be called stone dragons could so
pounce in some sense wake them bring
them back to life will we see sir pounce
riding a reanimated skeletal dragon what
could be called a flaming sword above
the world probably not azor Ahai as
prophesied to be born of the line of the
Mad King Aerys and realitor carrion this
one is tricky but Rey Ella had many
miscarriages and stillbirths and when
Daenerys suffers a stillbirth albeit a
magic induced one the char
resembles a lizard or dragon if
Targaryen z' can give birth to dragon
like children why not cat like children
could Queen rhaella Targaryen have given
birth to the black Tomcat that fathered
sir pounce interestingly we do know that
there was a black kitten in the
Targaryen family at the time a pet of
Princess Rhaenys called balerion Varys
tells us about this kitten and wonders
what happened to it many fans believe
that Valyrian stayed in the red cape and
grew up to be this Tomcat they're both
black the Tomcat is old and he seems to
hate Lannister's the family that killed
his dog Aryan masters Georgia our Martin
has said that this theory could be true
the Tomcat surpasses possible father
could be balerion the Targaryen pet so
if you're willing to believe the Queen
rhaella somehow gave birth to be leery
on the cat which you shouldn't but if
you are that means sir pounce son of
balerion is a secret Targaryen of the
line of Eris and ariela he's the
rightful ruler of Westeros ahead of
Daenerys for now he bides his time at
Tommen side but soon will rise to defend
his rights and fight for the light as
azor Ahai the pounce that was promised
King pounced Targaryen the first a hero
to deliver the world from darkness
except not really right Syrio Forel
tells iya a story he says the Sealord of
Braavos kept exotic creatures from
around the world and one day he showed
people one of his animals people saw a
fabulous exotic beasts but Serio looked
and said it's a cat just an ordinary cat
no more people saw a fabulous base
because that's where they expected and
wanted to see Syria says the heart lies
and the head plays tricks look with your
eyes then comes the thinking and in that
way knowing the truth the truth is that
so pounce is a cat yes he can maybe kind
of fit the signs of azor Ahai but
anything can seem to fit such vague
criteria when there's so much material
to cram into them this is how people
believe in quack medicine and young
Earth Creationism an illuminati
conspiracies amande maybe all the little
lies
tell ourselves each day pick specific
details apply some wishful thinking and
you can believe whatever you want to
believe to find the truth you've got a
step back look at the whole body of
evidence the broader context the bigger
picture in this case that a Song of Ice
and Fire is a story of human struggle
centered on people like John and
Daenerys the truth is that so pounce is
an ordinary cat no more but he could
still be the kitten of balerion so
that's pretty cool anyway thanks for
watching this ridiculous video and a
huge thank you to all the patrons who
pledged in support of the channel
including mr. Pfeffer si Jason ratray
metal and cockerel cruiser Caligula
Floridian coax us Carlos crystal Mason
Michael it's pretty damn cool
civilization ex and kawaii kitten night
we're getting very close to some major
funding milestones with enough support
old chief Tech's can go full time and
release big videos much more often so if
you'd like to see that happen and get
some sweet patron rewards please pledge
whatever you think the content is worth
at patreon.com slash alt shift X Cheers